IT IS TIME TO PLAY... ON MY WAY
TO STEAL YOUR GIRL: GIF EDITION.
(CHEERING, WHOOPING)
BY NOW YOU MAY HAVE COME ACROSS
ONE OF THE INTERNET'S FINEST
MEMES, ON MY WAY TO STEAL YOUR
GIRL, WHERE PEOPLE POST GIFS AND
PHOTOS, AND THEN, WITH CASANOVA
CONFIDENCE, HASHTAG IT: ON MY
WAY TO STEAL YOUR GIRL.
FOR EXAMPLE, THIS SHARPSHOOTING
SEGUE SLAYER. BAM!
(LAUGHTER)
ON MY WAY TO STEAL YOUR GIRL.
AND IF THAT FAILS, ON MY WAY TO
TEACH CHILDREN'S KARATE LESSONS
WAY TOO SERIOUSLY.
SO, COMEDIANS, I'M GONNA SHOW
YOU SOME SWEET GIFS WE FOUND
SEARCHING ON ON MY WAY TO STEAL
YOUR GIRL.
FOR 250 POINTS, I WANT YOU TO
TELL ME ANOTHER THING THEY'RE ON
THEIR WAY TO DO, ALL RIGHT?
THIS WIGGLY WANDY.
(LAUGHTER)
CHRIS D'ELIA.
>> ON THE WAY TO DRY MY PUSSY.
(LAUGHTER)
>> HARDWICK: I MEAN...
I WOULD HOPE IT'D BE DRY BY THE
TIME SHE GETS TO HERE.
>> YEAH, YEAH, YEAH.
>> HARDWICK: IAN EDWARDS.
>> ON MY WAY TO BEING A HUMAN
VAGINA ROOMBA.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
(LAUGHTER)
(APPLAUSE, WHOOPING)
>> HARDWICK: WAIT A MINUTE.
HANG ON A SECOND.
ISN'T THAT JUST THE WOMB-BA?
>> YES.
(AUDIENCE SHOUTING, GROANING)
>> VERY GOOD, MAN, VERY GOOD!
>> HARDWICK: NEXT ONE, HOW ABOUT
THIS PADDLING PUG?
MR. D'ELIA.
>> ON MY WAY TO DROWN YOUR SON.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
(LAUGHTER)
>> YOU COULD DEFINITELY SEE THAT
HAPPENING.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
LIKE IF... JUST PLAYFUL, THOUGH,
AND THE KID'S LIKE,
"HA-HA-HA-HA, GLUB-GLUB-GLUB,
HA-HA!" AND THEN ALL OF A
SUDDEN...
>> WHY DID IT HAVE TO BE A SON?
>> HARDWICK: BECAUSE I USED TO
BE ALLOWED UP ON THE COUCH
BEFORE YOU ARRIVED!
(LAUGHTER)
(GROWLS)
>> SO CUTE.
>> HARDWICK: NEXT UP, THIS
SQUATTING STALLION.
CHRIS D'ELIA.
>> ON MY WAY TO RAISE AWARENESS
ABOUT THE DANGERS OF POLIO.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
(LAUGHTER)
(APPLAUSE, WHOOPING)
POINTS.
WHITNEY CUMMINGS.
>> ON MY WAY TO [BLEEP] OUT
BRUNO MARS.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
YEP.
>> YOU DON'T THINK I COULD DO
THAT?
I COULD DO THAT, I COULD DO
THAT.
>> DO IT. DO IT.
>> DO IT. DO IT. DO IT.
(AUDIENCE SHOUTING, CHEERING)
>> WOW, WHOOPS.
>> (CROWD CHANTING): CHRIS,
CHRIS, CHRIS, CHRIS, CHRIS!
>> HEY, GUYS, GUYS, GUYS, GUYS,
GUYS, GUYS-- FULL DISCLOSURE:
I CAN'T DO THAT.
>> HARDWICK: OH.
I DON'T KNOW... WHAT IS IT THAT
HE'S DOING, THOUGH, IS IT
JUST... IS HE, HE'S JUST
DOING...
>> IT'S JUST... (IMITATES CRASH)
AND JUST BLEEDING.
>> OH, NO, NO.
CHRIS...
>> HARDWICK: IT'S REALLY HARDER
THAN IT LOOKS.
>> CHRIS, IF YOU DIE, LIKE FOUR
SHOWS WON'T HAVE A HOST.
SO PLEASE BE CAREFUL.
ALL RIGHT, NEXT ONE, THIS GOOFY
DUDE.
HUH, WHAT ABOUT THIS?
>> BY THE WAY, ON MY WAY TO
WHITNEY'S HOUSE 'CAUSE SHE'S
INTO IT.
>> HARDWICK: YEAH.
>> I'M NOT MAD AT THAT.
>> HARDWICK: I'M-I'M A SHOWER,
NOT A GROWER.
IAN.
>> UH, ON MY WAY BACK FROM
STEALING YOUR GIRL.
>> HARDWICK: YEAH, POINTS.